after nearly four years a wealth of
action and array of crazy costumes and
best of all and abundance of phenomenal
actors giving Suzanne Collins's novels
new life on the big screen The Hunger
Games franchise is finally coming to an
end so I wanted to look back over the
most heart in your mouth moments from
the final film Mockingjay part 2
obviously spoilers ahead if you haven't
seen the film already and if that's you
i've got a non-spoiler review right here
for you kicking off with number 5
Katniss hasn't even made it to the
Capitol to confront snow when she
already finds her life under threat
she's trying to rally district - Zoila
Stu the rebel cause let's just say
they're not exactly down with what the
Mockingjay has to say you've probably
didn't put them in the best of moods
that the rebels have just bombed them
and caused a bunch of avalanches and
just as one district - man relents after
putting a gun to Katniss's throat
another takes aim and hits his targets
thank goodness for that bulletproof
outfit hey at number four okay so even
if you haven't read the novel's just
hearing Boggs tell Katniss he's not
gonna let her die on his watch these are
feeling that he isn't long for this
world and tragically he's blown up just
after Katniss and her squads survive an
especially nasty gun trap one of the
many hellish hidden traps that make the
Capitol itself
feel like a big Hunger Games arena but
things go from bad to worse when the
next pod kicks off with what in the
movie looks like a shockingly real wave
of liquid tar or crude oil that hits the
courtyard like a tsunami forcing Katniss
and Coe to run for their lives to the
top floor of a nearby building then most
of them only just get away from that
building before snows trips arrive and
completely obliterate it
talk about tents moving on to number
three if you're not a fan of confined
spaces then Pollock's a suggestion that
Katniss and her crew go underground
quite likely sent a shiver down your
spine and oh my goodness when I saw
Pollux crawl on his stomach through that
tiny gap as they made their way through
the tunnel I swear I felt my stomach
turn over and as if the tunnels aren't
creepy and claustrophobic enough as it
is there's also a load of lizard mutants
thrown into the mix for some insanely
heart-stopping scenes which reminded me
both aliens and the British horror movie
The Descent as for the look of those
monstrous mutts that is I made me think
of the sort of beasts created by Pan's
Labyrinth director Guillermo del Toro
watching Katniss and her squad to battle
with those mutts in close quarters was
quite something
there was Gale shooting them in the head
and Finnick with his trident to name
just two
speaking of Finnick the sound of his
repeated screams for Katniss as he was
beset by those mutts was really chilling
and what about Katniss putting Finnick
out of his misery by detonating the holo
oh man and at number two in Mockingjay
part 1 you could already see that
president coin was a cool and
calculating cookie but she took that to
Anna rific extreme in part 2 when she
tricked Katniss snow and the people of
Panem into thinking that snow was the
one who dropped those exploding
parachutes and bombed the rebel medics
when it was actually her and like that
wasn't enough Coyne declared herself
interim president of Panem and we all
know how long her kind of interim would
have lasted plus she wanted to bring
back the games just symbolic Hunger
Games in lieu of barbaric executions as
she put it
vs. Katniss realized it was a case of
closer shows in Panem in other words all
they did was to swap a white-haired
dictator for a grey haired one so when
the moment came to step up and execute
Snow Katniss chose to shoot her arrow
into president coin instead freeing
Panem from coins dictatorship before it
really began and at the same time
avenging prims death and let's not
forget coins attempt to kill Katniss as
well for example by sending a still
traumatized Peter out to the Capitol
with Katniss his squad Corey thought she
was so clever didn't she and she was
arrogant the very last with her line may
your aim be as true as your heart is
pure and at number one it was Katniss
Everdeen desire to protect her sister
that saw her volunteer to take prims
place when she was picked as district 12
tribute back in the first Hunger Games
movie and ultimately it was that very
personal desire that set Katniss on the
roads become the Mockingjay a very
public symbol of rebellion against the
capital so what a terrible irony it was
that in the end
Katniss could not save both the people
of Panem and her own sister and the
whole way it played out was just
heartbreaking beginning with snows offer
of shelter to the refugees and their
children to his troops taking their kids
away from them at the gates of his
mansion to the hovercraft dropping
little parachutes like the ones sent to
tributes during the games except these
parachutes were bombs not medicine or
food - finally the rebel medics rushing
in Katniss sing prim calling out and
walking towards her only for second wave
of delayed bombs to go off killing prim
and glowing Katniss backwards turning
her into a literal girl on fire the
whole thing was truly horrifying now
what are the moments that shocked you
most in Mockingjay part 2 and what are
your favorite scenes in the movie tell
me in the comments below I've got a
special video on the way with things you
didn't know about the Hunger Games
Mockingjay and I'll add an annotation
here once it's live if you enjoyed this
video I really appreciate you liking and
sharing it and do subscribe for more
videos like this movie reviews and
things you didn't know thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers